an introduction once more so what is the
free energy principle specifically
specifically its relationship to a
theory of everything as that's what this
channel is about
right um
so
my usual response here is do you want
the the high road or the la or the or
the low road
um let's take the high road uh given
that we're talking about theories of
everything um
so
the free energy principle is a principle
of least action
so it's a method really it's put most
simply a method that allows you to
identify the most likely dynamics the
most likely way a process will unfold
what is the process that we're talking
about here um but we're talking about
things like you and me particles or
people um so the first thing to note is
that you can
apply
standard variational principles of least
action to any system specifically a
random dynamical system of the kind that
could be described by say a launchvan
equation that underwrites most of the
physics we know
but the special thing about the free
energy principle
is it tries to understand the
relationship of something
in relation to everything else
so you're starting from the premise that
something exists and then you have to
think carefully
what is a thing and how do i distinguish
it from something else so immediately
you start you have to introduce a
partition
between the states of things
um that comprise states that are
internal to the thing and states that
are outside the thing and
thereby
in think carefully about how those
states are coupled and what happens is
that you have to introduce a further set
of states known as blanket states
that constitute a markov blanket
that uh mediate a bi-directional
exchange between the internal states and
the external states so you've got this
um notion now of taking the states of
any universe
any system that you want to try and
understand
and partitioning it or carving it into
four subsets internal external and then
sensory inactive states that constitute
the blanket states where the active
states mediate the effects of the
internal on the external on the inside
on the outside
and the sensory states conversely
mediate the influences of the external
on the internal
so with this particular partition which
you wouldn't need if you wanted to now
just move on and develop
um
say quantum mechanics or statistical
mechanics or longitudinal classical
mechanics
now in the special case of dealing with
a system that has this partition
and in this special case
those conventional variational
principles of least action
translate into or
can be used
to associate the paths of least action
the most likely paths that the system
will take particularly the states of the
particle or person that we're talking
about
we can associate those paths at least
action with paths that minimize
something called variational free energy
so that's basically it and then the
story as well what's what's variation
free energy well variational free energy
is
as with all actions in physics it's just
a um a path integral or a time integral
uh a sum an accumulation of uh a
functional usually known as a lagrangian
where in this instance the funk the
functional in question this variational
free energy
can be read as exactly the same quantity
that statisticians
um psychologists
people trying to understand data
would treat as
a proxy for
the evidence for some model of the world
so this is known as bayesian model
evidence
statistically it's also known as a
marginal likelihood the likelihood of
these sensory data the sensory the path
through the sensory states
under a particular model that would try
to explain
a hypothesis that would try to explain
those data
so
you've got this interpretation or
certainly the fact that the functional
form
of this variation free energy that is
being minimized by the paths of least
action of the autonomous the active and
the internal states of something a
particle or a person
now looks as if it is trying to minimize
a quantity which provides an
approximation or a negative
approximation
to
marginal likelihood or moral evidencing
so in other words it looks as if the
most likely paths are trying to maximize
model evidence
so
one can read that in many different ways
one can read that
and
as jakob howie has read it
a philosopher neuroscientist who
has a a commitment and understanding to
this kind of formulation
as self evidencing literally
interacting with your
environment
actively inferring engaging with your
experienced world your eco niche
in a way that looks as if you're trying
to solicit
the most evidence
for your model of that world
this quantity is also found in machine
learning it's known as an evidence lower
bound i should um qualify or just
clarify that in machine learning this
free energy is the reverse of the free
energy used in physics so in machine
learning they try to maximize the
negative free energy um aka an evidence
lower bound or elbow um while in physics
you're you're always articulated in
terms of minimizing a potential energy
or minimizing in the citizens of
variation free energy
so you'll find that exactly
the same functional the same quantity
the same measure
of
uh the goodness of some model
of how you think your sensations your
censorium was generated
in terms of
the you know this
variational free energy
that leads you to an interpretation of
people particle persons
inferring
accumulating evidence making inferences
about the states of the world that are
generating their sensations
so that in a nutshell or perhaps not our
child isn't a formal explanation of the
free energy principle i did so slipping
in the beginning very much like um
things which you you know you may be
familiar with when you were at school
say hamilton's principle of station
reaction
it is
just a method you know it allows you
um to identify predict simulate engineer
those trajectories those paths those
dynamics those processes
um that will um minimize
the
this this action functional or the path
integral of the variation of free energy
so what that means is that
if you now understand
or have at hand the functional form of
your variation free energy
that depends upon
posterior beliefs or beliefs about the
outside world under a generative model
quite simply a probability density over
the external causes of the
consequences that are the sensory states
and then you can use that methodology
use that principle to start to simulate
to build sentient artifacts that behave
in the way that we assume under the free
energy principle that you and i are
behaving let's see if i can make a
nutshell of the nutshell for some people
who are more familiar with physics so
let's say you have a ball you want to
know the dynamics of the ball you can
understand this with newtonian force and
that's useful for certain calculations
or you can think of it as minimizing a
lagrangian and then that actually
provides a more useful for most cases
way of calculating the trajectory of the
ball so then right there when i said
ball we've identified the ball now here
you're not just limiting yourself to
balls you're saying let's say cells
instead of talking about people because
we can break it down simply at least for
me for myself i find it much more easy
to think of a cell okay so then we want
to know what are the dynamics of the
cell how is the cell a single cell going
to act
okay firstly the first step would be
identifying that cell and
when you mention the word markov blanket
that's a way of identifying what this
object is because in order to identify
what an object is it's often useful to
identify what it isn't at the same time
what it is and isn't so that markov
blanket delimits the cell now is that
correct so far absolutely yeah so you
know i think the cell is a perfect
example here you've got you know
a cell is just defined by the boundary
which would be the surface of the cell
and that would essentially be the
sensory states that i was talking about
before
the insides the intracellular states
would be the internal states and then
the milieu in which that cell lives
which is usually in
a bunch or a family of other cells
will constitute all the external states
so
you've made the very first step just
talking about a cell a thing you've
defined it in terms of this partition
into internal external and the uh the
sensory states that bound and separate
the inside from the outside you may be
asking where the active states come
first cell i usually like to associate
those with something called actin
filaments that just lie underneath the
surface the sensory states and
actively push the cell surface say oh
the philia um
the um
the mechanisms that cause motion of the
cell should it move around
so
those parts those states that are
responsible for cellular motility so if
we're now thinking about a moving cell
or swimming cell for example
and you need to supplement that
partition with with active stains so
that's absolutely the first step um and
then you're going to go on and now
translate the ball what's the ball
in this in this metaphor